قال المبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى اليمن
تيموثي لندر كينغ في تصريح للجزيره ان
هجمات الحوثيين تعرض اليمن للخطر واكد
ليندر كينج انه لن تكون هناك غارات جويه
من التحالف اذا لم تكن هناك هجمات على
السفن ما يجري يعرض اليمن للخطر ويضر به
ويعرقل عمليه السلام التي ساهم فيها
الحوثيون انفسهم يريد عكس الوضع الحالي
والابتعاد عن النشاط العسكري لن تكون هناك
غارات جويه للتحالف على قدراتهم او تصنيف
للحوثيين كمنظمه ارهابيه اذا لم تكن هناك
هجمات على السفن والقرار يعود
للحوثيين كما اكد ليندر كينج في تصريح
للجزيره ان الحوثيين ينقلون المعركه الى
المجتمع الدولي واعتبر ان ذلك ليس
بالطريقه المناسبه للتضامن مع
الفلسطينيين
الحوثيون اختاروا التعبير عن تضامنهم مع
الفلسطينيين وهو ما يشعر به العديد من
الامريكيين لكن هذه ليست هي الطريقه
المناسبه لذلك الحوثيون ينقلون المعركه
الى المجتمع الدولي الذي لا علاقه له
بمشكله غزه وما يفعلونه يعقد جهود نقل
الامدادات الى القطاع ويتسببون في رفع
تكاليف الشحن تبحر السفن حول القرن
الافريقي لمسافه 5 ميل اضافيه للوصول الى
شرق البحر الابيض المتوسط كما ان هذه
الهجمات تهدد ايضا المدنيين الابرياء في
السفن